did you ever go through a period of time
where you just were throwing yourself at
men because you wanted a man in your
life I think what I went through is I
had a phase of dating older men and
dating older guys because of my daddy
issues obviously yeah and now I'm at a
place where like I'm in an amazing
relationship and my boyfriend is a year
older than me and we're growing together
and it feels so healthy you know and
how'd you meet him we actually met in
the studio and
um so he's an artist but he's also a
songwriter so he came in to write on one
of my sessions and I was in the studio
and was like immediately attracted
immediately attracted to him yeah Lucky
Bastard he's so hot right oh he was a
good looking dude I wish I texted my
friends on the side and was like he's so
hot I'm in with this songwriter that's
so hot and you know what I mean yeah are
you sure he has a good personality or
are you just so enamored no he has the
best personality would laugh non-stop
yeah yeah what's this dude's name his
name is Jordan Lutz but he goes by juts
he even has like a cool name
what do you think you're gonna marry
this guy yeah I think so you think so
yeah he hasn't popped a question yet no
but we've talked about it really yeah
how seriously has it been how long has
it been it's been like a year and a half
all right we're taking our time with it
a little bit you know I mean because
you're a big star this for this guy I
feel bad because how do you make the
first move I'd be very careful with you
do you make the first move in order to
make it easy for him because you know
it's a strange thing when you're when
you're a superstar well what's funny is
like we started off as friends for the
first few months and oh this poor guy
and I was like oh there's no way he's
attracted to me like you felt yeah
you've never had a guy turn you down
have you I think it's happened more so
with girls oh really you read you
describe yourself as pansexual pansexual
yeah and that means
what you're just in love with the human
and women have rejected you I think you
know what what's happened in the past is
like they just want a hookup and it's
like I actually wanted something more
serious so it ends up not working isn't
that weird you would think the opposite
you would think guys would just want the
hook up yeah and you and you get
tremendously hurt by that I'm sure yeah
especially when you like the girl you
know it was definitely painful I'd like
to meet the girl that just wanted a
one-nighter with you I really would it's
crazy to me but you think this guy is
the one for you yeah I know why why is
he so great
he's so great because you know what it
is we started off as friends so we built
that Foundation of friendship first and
then I do that with every girl but then
it never goes with it never goes to
anything I'm like hey everyone's my
friend that's awesome there's like this
partnership there that is just so
magnetic and the way that we laugh
together it's just non-stop so I think
if you can find someone that you know
makes you feel safe makes you that
you're so attracted to that you know you
laugh with constantly that's the formula
of like a really great relationship I
love romance don't you yeah it's so
great when it works out oh yeah you want
to have his kids yeah definitely oh this
is serious yeah
take it easy
um juice is loved by everyone
foreign